сонців 2017 рік буду ви вирішували для is a
jam та мого вибору 3 ключові краї нах
з та їх не результати будуть душі промо
вас там і чим упокоїти вас миші на весь
сонячному включайте вибори ендери
концерт вже на спокій я з ти ж столітті всієї
за дебатами біля США
віддаються безпрецедентна ситуація судити
6 ще нам відома
за картоне граф з ума вірного пов'язання
з-за кордон йому поруч готелі connect
with forthcoming
дозволь там вони будуть уже обидва режимі
домагалася а ми не кулю вати
узбіччям менше зла мати бази даних
політичних інститутів стиснути
я торкається було можна з отриманих штатах
ти так вже очевидно можна його труби ти і
в Європі іншими словами ми можемо розум від
nlhe маніпуляції через пий до винен та
на них клеюча затвора не індивідуально
обидві групами радикалами
з правого обидва лівого крила лев уралсиб
ми також можемо таки вмотати з проби
збоку у regius я яким не личить це
переліку наші ряди і он і створі
вставити проблему
опосередковано до його випалений новий святий і
ми моєму шляху готуємо їжу тихенько в
один із цик закордонних побачивши пройти
його душі у ураженого міста з і росія
особи завгодно харчування я до Європи злегка
видачі сис росію з путіним шина частина
з нового доводи dialogs крим стрічкою
[музика]
видалити північ абсолютно
я повністю Петро і мою продовження справу
в росію на всіх ременя рулет
не позбавлена ​​рівні міністр закордонних
справляв добро
я думаю керрі і лаврів ви витрачали багата
худим і безшумний бачіли це діалог і
контакт між людьми що мають
рішення пустирі оборони добра sen
menimsen серія практично mojet
наводила між російськими здвоєними
силами із шаблону то я за такі контакти
однак 1 годину давай тягни гір це процес
відкрито
Росія буде послухатися то наших ви
бог кільки як що ми будемо одягнені
базу та частину на наших владних посилань та
сильно стягувати менше ви словом і я
знайду маються доброго д ти та проплати
діалог росія кмнс смузі дієти розум
бачив я говорю про с екімова біля рити
єдиним голосом я ще євросоюз ми дуже
стильно позицію у криму і замкнув міняє
мій шлях його президента США диво
петренко нарешті я думаю ми мати йому
добрі заснув для серйозного діалогу з
Росією може вивіз літру хоча в на
премію нової стратегії чистої води мішер
фтс я думаю нам потрібно також стратегія
ревнувала у видно цінах між
отриманим штатам це росію всього поки що
не було
ми не можемо опитування на 50 частки мовчки
всередину знесу порядок про ітан України про
ітани із серії the wings
нескладного буду голову не це взвод ж
щодо Росії і все Європа помочити пул
голки не відомий лише вашингтоном і
москвою notekino c black
владимир путін нам а гаїті ви просто ти
проти дональда трампа вбив їм і від
чоловіки весь для на лаві jeunesse ту
сумки я маю 2 за повагу з тіла приводу
по 1 ц
однозначно краще ви вночі на користь
європейцям та в інтересах Європи по
бачать серйозний стратегічний діалог
між вашингтоном та москвою
маска навчу вас троє теджо слухаючи 100
тис той сіток а форма стратегічний
встиг простягнеш з шато р.ф. я кому ж на
skoda т європейським союзникам ютюбе
cd and you can create izovat і я
категорично про ти музику і
російсько-американської біля води пляшкою
нібито зробила до послаблення україни
прикладом daikin форекс облав україни
обозу за рішенням європейського
колективного значення російської
поєдинки у криму та на сході України та
треба бути іншими словами ми маймоніда
порожні ти вдома
він із тієї за спинами європейських
союзників голі діти проти інтересів
шукають над холодильником
awards and you're a piece of the baltics
травня на уазі вкрай балки пошукаю та інших
союзники по тому ось це дуже важливо
і я сподіваюся ще адміністрація трампу
за 15 ще петри моя важливу роль на так а
мій буднів президент трамп виходьте
масово друк своїх зустрічей із володимиром
Путін ще трамп відразу ми ще знаємо не
просто
по путін у політиці набагато душі не
штром думаю вона трампу стану тобі домище
за якою протизастудних місяців
мандат барбато діна фільму не буде якщо
ви там європу може завершити залишок
засудивши вашингтона та Москви буланів
гарна
[музика]
Європа сама травня заявить про себе з
нинішньої ш
економічна сила у свиті ми найбільшою
світловий торги важливий блок
ми представляємо 500 мільйонів людей
ланцюг чотири рази більший за населення Росії
сама ж у 2 год більше населена з
отриманих штатів
що ми недооцінюємо себе чому нам з
пробувати грати у прем'єр лізі
cfc вирішила ти на інотропію вашингтон з
моя взята з роботи свої заяви
і пояс немає на увазі чим і нас правді ту
а можуть жодна clash підсумку я ще ми
будемо єдиними у нашій позиції
встигають volvo ec